that's gonna be an amazing game that one
can definitely go either way but before
we get that we are getting mob versus
prison it is the lars versus the leroy
so prison coming to that lee right here
today he is really on the dark side
right now
come to forgotten realm where the
structural integrity is top class
all it takes is one little tap and that
all goes in available for voiceovers
a nice black force that's a great option
there from mob gonna be a lot of options
that they go for that back four is gonna
be huge whenever you see frisian going
to hermit studs we're gonna see mob do
that a lot because that's the classic
savaki that lyra players will do there
or doesn't work on
i these see bob he wants to get in and
force a full crouch game he just like
doing it but frison was ready for it
that wasn't that we've punished there
from prison but not a good combo at all
he might have been able to kill this new
race drive 142 into the follow-up nice
block but that's not it nice block right
back
one more hit does it could have done
more though
oh my goodness
i thought that i i thought for sure that
i was gonna hit i thought for sure
great
breaks the floor immediately
he just showed good awareness just to
carry on nonetheless and not get phased
by it all backfires
cool pressing buttons no punish there on
whilst anyone prison not looking good
right now doesn't duck the second half
down three two you have to duck it if
you want to get the full launch
budget hell sweep hits him
challenge
mob does not care right now great start
here for mob yeah i think unfortunately
for frison though he should have had
that first uh first round
is it gonna be ten thousand nine hundred
and thirty nine wins lmg mob i know
that's the question you're all asking
too many wins
that's a lot attacking
best moves in the game at the back four
count it again things looking so good
right now for mob the backwards workout
but again not a good combo by frison he
might be able to kill him he did that
correctly nice patience by mob down two
oh my goodness frisian isn't done yet
but he needs to get his combos sorted
out
not all mob getting so much juice out of
fat four as well it does five more
damage this season and he's really using
it well
what's the okay oh nice the hermit parry
is gonna go for a mix up here
doesn't work out nice patience there for
mob again just to dig that dick jab
string twice and prison stays the line
alive fighting around first game
doubtful one backing up slowing it down
a little bit now oh
from out of nowhere this was looking
like it was gonna be mob's game but
maybe not right now
mom does duck up in your grill quite a
lot so if you're going to make the
wreath
it's going to play oh those wall bounce
he's going for herself nice patience
there from prison a swiping swipe
down one he went for the cane didn't
work out and just like that mob will
take the first game and that was what
about the closest games i've had this
topic let's be honest
yeah i mean i'm confused wasn't frison
just winning that round like
didn't he just spend niddy all that
around winning and then then mob just
spent five seconds taking all that lead
away that was crazy
you know um but yeah one thing i like
about um back four technically didn't
get buffed when you think about it this
season because like you said it gives
the extra 5
damage but in season 4 they actually
added extra 5 health to the game so
technically it's not even a buff it just
does what it should have done it's just
more
inflation damage inflation i like it
usually just inflation right there um
but yeah great start there for mob but
frison he's looking in this this is
definitely a lot closer than when they
played an evil online uh frison could
have taken that game the first run you
have to say should have been his but he
just messed up i want to see prison
needs to do better combos you can't keep
do it you can't leave so much damage on
the table especially against someone
like mob is always ready to come back at
you so you need to end this game as fast
as possible
i agree i agree i think one of the
things mob does from watching the way he
plays is that he's looking to get up in
your grill and do uh full crouch mix-ups
and really make you make some reads and
he doesn't just sit there in full crouch
waiting for you to duck like you know
maybe a lead player might do he he's
very quick and he makes you make lots of
micro decisions all the time so be
interesting to see how frison reacts to
that he's chosen arena i mean
for me it's just like an equalizing
stage i mean i don't think this is
necessarily is going to change things
significantly for him other than take
away some of the bs
i mean with the water
is uh
anyone's game here but mob takes the
first hit very nice start nice pace
again using that back four to beat
sabaccy he chooses to go for it nice
punish
prison just swinging right now needs to
get something started
yeah lots of whiffs
and again it's very hard to replenish
that though
great calendar hit there by more great
start as well goes for the wall bounce
just shy oh no that's it
yeah
great patience there from mob and it's
just all the time with the audience to
sit there in there it was
rare you see someone so effectively
whiff punish a cane but they came by
from range as well very good
going to the whoa whoa
oh you do not see this every single day
and just like that one more one but this
is the thing prison made the two-round
comeback before can he do it again
he's gonna have to do it
the hard way this is looking tough
okay this is becky or the door
nice side step
could have got more maybe
okay down three two not done yet punish
that yeah that's -14 perfect punish
there from mob and he is going to take
the game over frison two oh and the stop
do you see the stomach just standing
there
right you see that his shoulders back
looking good good posture and everything
you like to see that
one word for it okay
that was that was
dominant
my